but the sound that everybody here
is a flint son it's not even Detroit you
did what I'm saying
you might hear more of a Rio and Mike or
try to make some yeah shout out to Flint
that was one of the best funniest
interviews I've ever done Mike shout out
to Reed but the sign that y'all here
like the the funny the funny rap is like
Fast yeah no no like no choruses
that's really not a Detroit sound it's
more of a flint song like real and Mike
in them is kind of like the four or five
is of that you know how's Rio doing real
excellent real super straight real be
home soon yeah dude do we know when he's
gonna be out no I can't even I can't
announce the date but he'll be on soon
yeah yeah that's a hell of a well you
you guys are a one-two punch man oh man
it's crazy